they created something spectacular you
got so emotional about it oh my God this
is the Holy
Grail it was a watershed moment for the
industry video Gamers across the country
are anxiously awaiting the midnight
release of a game called Halo
2 November marks the 10-year anniversary
of Halo 2 and I am excited to tell you
that Halo 2 is getting the full
anniversary
treatment the puzzle becomes how do you
honor the material how do you keep it
fresh and interesting for you know a new
generation at the end of the day
everybody has one thing in common and
that is a love for what we're doing and
a passion to make this the best it can
be